Dies ist der Teaser zu unserem aktuellen Salon. Die Debatten derzeit sind merkwürdig. Hier nur ein Beispiel. Gestern gab Jan Böhmermann der Süddeutschen Zeitung ein Interview und sagte, links, rechts, nebensächlich. Die entscheidende Trennlinie verläuft zwischen demokratisch und totalitär. Aber kommt man wirklich mit dieser einfachen Unterscheidung weiter? Nein, natürlich nicht. Es ist etwas komplizierter und das erklärt uns die Soziologie. Wir sprechen im aktuellen Salon über das Buch Zerstörungslust von Karolin Amlinger und Oliver Nachtwey. Es geht um die Elemente des demokratischen Faschismus. Das klingt erst einmal widersprüchlich, aber wir bekommen sehr gute Aufklärung, warum das durchaus zusammengehen kann. Und wenn man nicht mehr bereit ist, in links und rechts zu unterscheiden, wenn man einfach sagt, da auf der einen Seite ist Demokratie, Liberalismus, Freiheit, auf der anderen Seite Faschismus, Totalitäres, dann macht man es sich zu leicht. Vor allem verkennt man, wie Amlinger und Nachtwey uns zeigen, dass der Liberalismus mit seinem Konkurrenzsystem selbst faschistische Züge hervorbringt. Über dieses Buch diskutieren wir ausführlich. Hier zunächst der Teaser.
Hallo Wolfgang.
Hallo Stefan.
Wann hast du zuletzt deinen Need for Chaos gespürt?
Als ich meinen Honorar vom bayerischen Rundfunk nicht bekam.
Erzähl, was passiert.
Ich hatte einen Dreh mit dem bayerischen Fernsehen und das hat doch alles großen Spaß gemacht. Und dann begann die elende Bürokratie mit mehreren Formularen.
Musstest du den Beruf deiner Eltern angeben auf dem Formular?
Solche Dinge bis hin, dass die Steuerberaterin sich noch mal dort melden musste und das ging wirklich über Wochen. Und es handelt sich um keinen hohen Betrag. Ich kann dir sagen, es waren 500 Euro. Das ist also jetzt nicht etwas, wo man sagt. So weiter muss man aber auch nochmal drei Anwälte prüfen lassen. Und es ging und ging nicht weiter. Und ich hab dann auch irgendwann schon geschrieben, es wäre doch jetzt auch mal an der Zeit, wenn wir das einfach mal schnell lösen. Ich kann auch einfach eine Rechnung schreiben. Und es ging also immer noch weiter das Spiel, bis ich dann etwa 10, 12 Wochen nach dem Engagement endlich Geld bekam, aber nur zwei Drittel dieser 500 Euro. Das ist nur ein Drittel und dann wurde mir gesagt, dass das mehr nicht vorgesehen sei für solche Auftritte. Und dann sagte ich, aber ich habe ja mit der Produktionsfirma oder mit der Produktion genau das abgesprochen. Und dann ging das immer noch mal weiter, weiter und weiter. Und dann war man auch, als ich dann telefonierte, immer noch uneinsichtig, bis ich dann dieser sehr uneinsichtigen Person am Telefon sagte, da kann man ja nur hoffen, dass dieses System endlich zusammenbricht. Das sagte ich, ja. Und ich glaube, sie hat gelacht. Ich weiß aber nicht, ob sie über mich gelacht hat oder ob sie es als Pointe gesehen hat. Aber ich habe es damals in dem Moment nicht als Pointe gemeint, weil das einfach eine Zumutung ist und dass ich das auch nie mehr für so wenig Geld machen werde, weil das einfach auf keine Kuhhaut geht. Und ich zugleich, also während ich da sprach, einfach an die, ich sag mal ganz deutlich Idioten dachte, die im Öffentlich-Rechtlichen Geld vorne und hinten reingesteckt bekommen ohne Ende und wo alles geht und wo dann diese Leute, die dann engagiert werden und sich dann ja hinreißen lassen, das für wenig Geld zu machen, damit man sagt, ach, das ist aber eigentlich ein schönes Projekt, dass man sich dann noch da so nieder machen muss, um 180 Euro zu bekommen. Ja, also jedenfalls war das der Punkt, an dem ich dachte, es wäre doch eigentlich gut, wenn das öffentlich-rechtliche System zusammenbricht. Jetzt würde ich das ein bisschen differenzierter betrachten, aber in dem Moment hätte ich gerne den roten Knopf gedrückt und kann aber sagen, ich habe inzwischen das Geld nach, ich glaube, 14 Wochen, nee, 16 Wochen endlich erhalten.
Sehr gut. Ich war ja auch einmal beim MDR und da war das auch so aufwendig. Sieben Seiten sollte ich ausfüllen, inklusive Beruf der Eltern, weil ich war ja kurz angestellt dort für diese Sendung.
Für 90 Minuten, ja.
Und am Ende, der letzte Schritt war, dass ich den Ausdruck meiner Unterschrift nochmal schicken musste mit den vorhergehenden sieben Seiten, weil die Archivordnung vorsieht, dass sie nicht dort einfach ausdrücken können, was sie mir zuschicken und ich dann einfach nur das Blatt mit der Unterschrift hinschicke, sondern nein, in meinem Brief müssen alle Seiten sein. Auch die, die ich nicht unterschreibe.
Ja.
Das sagt die Archivordnung des MDR. Also musste ich das alles nochmal ausdrücken und nochmal dahinschicken.
Brotesk.
Nun würden Karolin Amlinger und Oliver Nachtwey vielleicht sagen, ja, das mit der Bürokratie, das kann man natürlich bemängeln, aber unsere Gesellschaft ist so unglaublich komplex geworden, dass nun vieles nicht mehr so einfach geht. Wir springen jetzt schon mitten rein ins Buch. Wir gehen gleich zum Anfang, keine Sorge. Aber sie sagen ja, in einer Gesellschaft, in der man zum Beispiel hin- und herfliegen kann, von Frankfurt nach Berlin, sind mehr Dinge zu regeln als in einer Gesellschaft, in der man sich mit der Kutsche fortbewegt. Und das stimmt erst mal so. Ich glaube aber, dennoch ist zum Teil Disruption dringend nötig. Aber wir sehen auch, der Neoliberalismus, der eigentlich gesagt hat, wir bauen Bürokratie ab, hat noch viel mehr Regeln geschaffen. Und genau das ist ja auch so im Öffentlich-Rechtlichen zu sehen. Dadurch, dass hier plötzlich jedes Mittel gerechtfertigt werden muss, da muss jeder nochmal extra drüber entscheiden, hat man natürlich ein System geschaffen, in dem jede Taxi-Quittung durch 17 Hände gehen muss. So dass am Ende derjenige, der die Taxi-Quittung gerne zurückerstattet hätte, sich sagt, ich lasse es, ich zahle sie lieber selbst. Das ist das eine System. Zum anderen hat man natürlich mit dem Öffentlich-Rechtlichen System gebaut, bei dem es einzelne Personen gibt, die damit immens reich werden. Die gründen nämlich ihre eigenen privaten Produktionsfirmen und dann stellen die für die produzierten Talkshows oder andere Sendungen irgendwelche horrenden Rechnungen, haben dann Mondpreise, die sie abrufen, haben 70 Mitarbeiter, die eine einzige Talkshow produzieren. Man denkt sich, was machen die da alles? Das war ja selbst in der DDR nicht so. So viele Leute, so wenig Arbeit. Ja, also so ein Irrsinn. Und das ist auch ein System, das man damit produziert hat. Und darunter haben dann diejenigen zu leiden, die da irgendwie mal frei sind. Und natürlich am Ende auch der Frau, der euch das am Telefon gesagt hat. Ich hätte es ja gerne dem Intendanten gesagt, aber ich konnte es ja auch nur einer Sachbearbeiterin sagen. Die muss ich aber auch hier nochmal betonen, sich wirklich nicht gerade mit Ruhm bekleckert hat.
Ja, du hast also die Erfahrung gemacht, dass nicht dein ganzes Leben, aber in Abschnitten dann doch, eine Blockierung stattfindet.
Richtig.
Denn egal wie obskur die Bürokratie ist, sie wird ja gefühlt als sie hindert mich, sie blockiert mich, das blockierte Leben. Jetzt hast du dir das Recht genommen, ein Thema mitten aus dem Buch, ich mach das jetzt auch. Denn dieses Buch besprechen wir ja in einer Reihe vieler Bücher und es droht ja immer wieder, dass wir so Kritik auch wiederholen, wenn ein Buch mal wieder nicht verspricht, was wir vorher schon bei anderen bemängelt haben. Und einer dieser großen Mängellagen war ja, wo ist denn hier das Ökonomische?
Ja.
Der Kapitalismus, wie auch immer. Und ich habe ja schon bei Nils Kumka angemerkt, nein, sein Desiderat zum Thema wir haben keine Theorie des Rechtspopulismus hat ja Punkt eins, ökonomische Aufklärung. Deswegen möchte ich die zentrale, finale Point dieses Buches jetzt gleich einfach nennen, indem ich sie vorlese und dann auf ein Textteil mitten im Text einschwenken. Also die letzten Worte dieses Buches lauten, so viel die interviewten Personen, nein, wir sind so frei, abschließend ein bekanntes Diktum Max Horkheimers, ein wenig zu ergänzen. Wer aber vom Kapitalismus und vom Liberalismus nicht reden will, sollte auch vom Faschismus schweigen. Jetzt haben wir uns ja gefragt, da steht demokratischer Faschismus drauf. Was ist Faschismus? Faschismus, wenn man überhaupt darüber redet, dann bitte nicht im Gefühlsduse liegen, das war ja damals schon zu schlimm, als die Fernsehbilder noch schwarz-weiß waren und so, sondern Faschismus ist eins zu eins irgendwas mit Ökonomie. Wenn das mit der Ökonomie da nicht vorkommt, dann darf man das Wort Faschismus einfach nicht nennen. Diese ganz wichtige Forderung hier am Ende des Buches prägt das ganze Buch, würde ich sagen. Also einer der großen Kritikpunkte, die wir bisher hatten, oder in dem Falle du, bei Kumpka, aber auch so bei anderen, dass die Ökonomie hier zu kurz kommt, ist in diesem Falle, also das können wir schon mal vorher sagen, wir haben ein Buch, das sehr viel näher ankommt.
Bei Reckwitz hat mir das ganz stark herausgearbeitet.
Da bin ich auch völlig einer Meinung.
Ja, bei Kumpka hast du es anders gesehen, oder auch andere Dinge in den Fokus rückt, aber bei Reckwitz reden wir die ganze Zeit über Verlust und man denkt, Bilanzen, Verlust, Geld, das müsste doch eigentlich ganz nahe liegen. Und hier haben wir es und ich will das nur sagen für die Leute, die dieses berühmte Diktum nicht kennen von Max Horkheimer. Das heißt ja eigentlich nur, wer aber vom Kapitalismus nicht reden will. Und sie erweitern es jetzt nochmal, wer vom Kapitalismus und Liberalismus nicht reden will, bedeutet also, wir verteidigen jetzt gerade mit diesem Buch nicht den Liberalismus gegen den Faschismus. Das wäre so das nächste Wohlfühlsachbuch. Wir kennen diese Sachen.
Precht, Wagenknecht, die...
Sondern wir sehen jetzt hier, ach so, der Liberalismus selbst ist offenbar mitbeteiligt an dieser Entstehung des demokratischen Faschismus.
Genau. Also wir kriegen hier auch eine große Reaktion auf sowas wie Gejammer über die Selbstgerechten, wo wir uns immer sagen, das geht irgendwie am Ziel vorbei. Und hier geht's mal richtig rein. Aber mir geht es um noch einen anderen Punkt, den ich auch für ganz wichtig halte. Also sie schreiben so mittendrin. Soviel die interviewten Personen alle möglichen politischen und gesellschaftlichen Akteure und Fehlentwicklung kritisieren, bleibt ein Aspekt davon fast vollständig verschont der Kapitalismus.
Ja.
Das geht natürlich jetzt voll in unsere Kerbe, aber ich möchte es noch erweitern. Der Kapitalismus ist eine Schiffre für die Realität.
Ich will es also nochmal vorlesen. Soviel die interviewten Personen alle möglichen politischen und gesellschaftlichen Akteure und Fehlentwicklung kritisierten, bleibt ein Aspekt davon fast vollständig verschont die Realität. Ja. Wir erleben hier ein Buch, das uns erklärt, wie krass wir alle in so einer Fantasywelt leben. Und insbesondere diejenigen, die sie so ein Bild von der Gesellschaft machen, in der sie einfach nur rudimentäres Handlungsvermögen wieder reinbringen wollen durch Zerstörung. Wenn es brennt, sehe ich, das ist mal richtig was anderes und ich wünsche mir eine Änderung.
Ja, das Fiktionale ist ja da interessant. Das Fiktionale löst sich von der Realität. Aber eigentlich hat ja die Fiktion, die wir jetzt im Kino verfolgen, doch zum Beispiel den Wunsch, plausibel zu sein. Wir sagen, sonst ist da ja ein Logikloch. Aber hier werden wir jetzt Fiktionen erleben, die nicht logisch sind, die sind nicht konsistent. Das war der Teaser. Stefan und ich sprechen insgesamt zweieinhalb Stunden über Zerstörungslust von Caroline Amlinger und Oliver Nachtwey. Wir gehen tief rein in die Diskussion, schauen uns vor allem auch die Empirie an, die ganz erstaunlich ist. Wir sehen, ja, es gibt die radikalisierten Männer, aber es gibt auch die radikalisierten Frauen, die sich in unglaublich drastischer Weise äußern, die Vernichtungsfantasien einfach mal so artikulieren. Es ist ein unheimliches Buch über das es sich lohnt, länger nachzudenken. Außerdem gibt es dann natürlich noch unsere Literatur Empfehlungen des Monats. Das alles kann man hören, wenn man uns abonniert. Über Steady, das empfehlen wir besonders, ist das möglich. Über Apple und Patreon. Die Links findet ihr alle auf der Homepage und in der Beschreibung. Vielen Dank.